I love Sal you know what I went meant to
ask him is he vaping again Oh how's he
doing with that we really need to check
in yes I here's your pen gives you juice
want me to throw it out right now
it's a big moment do it you're strong
enough
I'll throw garbage right now and you're
doing do it before he tells us what
would you what we do babes I'm with you
on that
he better be honest I guarantee you he
begged because if you're not honest
we're gonna catch you anyway Fred what
do you think you know what I'm gonna
give him the benefit of the doubt I'll
say no he's quit no way he doesn't have
the willpower Sal do me a favor I don't
mean to bust your balls all day just
give me the answer I quit beeping so
Fred is right you haven't had one vape
and you you Robin and you all right
because I did Saturday night I was at a
poker game and I did vape a little bit
okay so let me clarify the answer bread
is wrong and Robin and I are right Fred
is right that I quit and you know we
know you quit but you broke down and
baby but I quit some Fred's right no one
day sandy does go on all day in your
life Howard everybody let me ask you
something I quit eating chocolate ice
cream yes but on Saturday night I had
chocolate ice cream did I quit eating
chocolate ice cream you quit but you had
a relapse all right so the engine didn't
quit well like I quit I had a relapse
and I quit again so I did I quit yeah
yes I had did I have a real on being so
no he's when Robin and I posed a
question and I said to Robin I you know
Robin said I believe Sal could not have
the willpower to stay off babe
right and that he went back to it and I
said Robin I agree with you yes and then
Fred said I'm thinking style actually
stayed off it we both can't be right yes
Fred Ronnie Lee right and you and Robin
are wrong because I quit I had a relapse
and the quitting
you quit and then you started again no I
started a little bit
and then I went back to the quit mode no
the simple answer is you could not quit
now you're trying again which is
quitting I'm in quit mode no no you quit
I quit and then you started again and
then I went back to quitting so which
quit stop saying no but every time we
finish vaping you've quit vaping until
your ready to vape again so yeah I quit
breathing but wait I just took another
breath did I quit breathing at that
moment yes let me ask you me what
happened when you started again what
happened was it was at poker game
Saturday night go ahead and we were
drinking and we were playing poker
who's we my friends we have a poker
tournament there are people who hang out
with can you believe it no honestly I
did I would I would be afraid of losing
my brain cells so you know you drinking
your gambling we're having fun
some guy there is vaping and then I
baked a little bit and that's and then I
stopped beeping the next day and then
and I told my children as well I said
look I'm stopped vaping I said I did a
little bit and I said but I go I want to
continue to quit vaping very No and when
I continue to quit I want it so how many
days off babe have you now well Saturday
no I know you smoked
right so Sunday much so today's a day
and a half one day a day in an 8 Robin a
day in an 8